TV might be all about enjoying a little
bit of escapism but sometimes the real
world gets in the way and there's no
more shocking an example of this than
when a beloved actor dies forcing a show
to say goodbye to the character they
played
Miguel Ferrer was part of an
accomplished Show Business family he was
the son of oscar-winning actor Jose
Ferrer and 50s pop singer Rosemary
Clooney as well as a cousin of Superstar
George Clooney a prolific actor he
joined the cast of cbs's NCIS Los
Angeles in 2012 to play Owen Granger
assistant director of the NCIS and
overseer of the office of special
projects in the LA Branch ostensibly
arriving to hunt down a killer he's
really there to keep an eye on the
show's regular Squad and bring his
experience as a CIA officer to the team
in a 2016 episode A.D Granger tells his
colleagues that he's dying from a form
of cancer possibly related to exposure
to agent orange during his time carrying
out government missions in Southeast
Asia Granger later disappears
disappearing from his hospital bed and
presumably dying from terminal cancer
off screen by the time Granger's
storyline was wrapped in 2017 Ferrer had
died too like his character Ferrer had
been suffering from cancer and passed
away the same year at the age of 61.
after a few years plying his trade as
film actor John Ritter returned to
television in 2002's eight simple rules
for dating my teenage daughter and TV
has always been good to him he won an
Emmy for his work on Three's Company and
he starred for three years on the 90s
CBS rom-com hearts of fire in eight
simple rules Ritter played befuddled
Family Man Paul Hennessy who's deeply
anxious about his kids aging into
rebellious independent teams Ritter had
only filmed one full season of the ABC
sitcom when he fell ill on set in
September 2003 complaining of nausea
weakness and chest pain later that day
54 year old Ritter had died of an
undiagnosed heart ailment called an
aortic dissection after a brief Hiatus
eight simple rules returned to
television necessarily revamped due to
the loss of its star the two-part
episode goodbye reveals that Paul died
after collapsing at the grocery store in
subsequent episodes James Garner and
David Spade joined the cast as Grandpa
Jim and nephew CJ respectively who move
in to help the widowed Kate Hennessy
raise her three kids
will Lee was a regular presence on
Sesame Street from the beginning
portraying Mr Hooper the kindly
proprietor of Hooper's store Big Bird
absolutely adores the sweet old man and
not just because he mixes up a mean bird
seed milkshake Lee made public
appearances as Mr Hooper and recorded
segments for Sesame Street up until
November 1982. one month later Lee died
of a heart attack in New York City's
Linux Hill hospital at the age of 74. a
survey conducted shortly before his
death found that Mr Hooper was the most
recognized human adult on Sesame Street
in the wake of his passing Sesame Street
producers were left with the Monumental
task of having to explain the death of
Mr Hooper and the concept of death in
general to an audience of extremely
young and emotionally vulnerable
children the series ultimately decided
to tackle this issue head on with the
help of some Consulting child
psychologists airing on Thanksgiving Day
1983 the absolutely heartbreaking
episode in question finds the childlike
Big Bird unable to locate Mr Hooper and
the adults on Sesame Street gently
explaining to him that the old
shopkeeper has died and the death is
final
you know
Gonna Miss You Mr Looper
that's a Hooper big bird
as big bird learns it's okay to be sad
about loss but also that Mr Hooper will
live forever in the memories of all who
loved him
Nicholas colasandro worked extensively
in television in the 1960s and 1970s
both as an actor and as a director in
1982 he started work on Cheers
portraying Ernie pantuso the easygoing
bartender who'd once coached bar owner
Sam Malone in his baseball days coach
became colasanto's most recognizable
role which is a truly impressive feat
given the breadth of his career when he
was cast on Cheers colasanto was well
into his 50s and already suffering from
heart problems his health took a turn
for the worse in late 1984. following a
hospitalization for water in his lungs
he couldn't get medical clearance to
return to the rigors of shooting cheers
in February 1985 the 61 year old actor
died of a heart attack a few months
later Woody Harrelson joined the cast as
cheers new bartender Woody Boyd
following a brief explanation of coach's
passing coach is mentioned sporadically
through the rest of the show's run
Phil Hartman dominated Saturday Night
Live during his nine-year stint on the
show but he then moved on to another
iconic Ensemble show NBC's workplace
sitcom news radio Hartman played Bill
McNeil an obnoxious rude self-absorbed
news reader for New York City radio
station wnyx he portrayed the part with
relish from 1995 to 1998 making his
final appearance in the Titanic themed
fourth season finale in May 1998 before
the fifth season of News Radio went into
production Hartman's difficult marriage
to wife Bryn omdal ended an unspeakable
tragedy the deeply troubled model and
actress shot a sleeping Hartman to death
then took her own life Hartman was just
49 years old news radio's Fifth Season
which aired The Following fall begins
with Bill moves on in which the wnyx
team heads to the office after the
funeral of Bill McNeil said to have died
from a heart attack most of the episode
consists of the other characters talking
about Bill and even openly crying tears
that might well have been real and could
easily have been shed for Hartman
himself
Riverdale is the place where multiple
generations of iconic teen pop culture
converge based on the classic Archie
comic stable of characters the CW Series
deposits them in a dreary foggy Twin
peaks-like Town absolutely Rife with
dark doings many of the grown-ups are
portrayed by Teen Idols of yore
including 80s brat Packer Molly Ringwald
as Archie's mother and Beverly Hills
90210's Luke Perry as Archie's wise and
doting Father Fred Andrews in the first
episode of season four Archie finds out
that his father has unexpectedly been
killed by a hit-and-run driver after he
stopped to help a stranded motorist
played by Perry's own 90210 love
interest Shannon Doherty that abrupt
Choice came about due to the tragic
real-life death of the actor in February
2019 Perry suffered a severe stroke at
the age of 52 and was immediately
hospitalized and placed in a medically
induced coma he died just a few days
later
The Sopranos blue audiences away with
its uniquely thoughtful exploration of
what makes a man turn to a life of
violent crime Tony Soprano really is a
complicated guy he's a mob boss and a
family man who has his Rivals killed but
then needs to discuss it with his
therapist and The Sopranos suggest that
a lot of Tony's anguish and emotional
pain stems from his mother Livia a
manipulative self-serving and
conspiratorial abuser Nancy Marchand
played the character with a fascinating
chilling intensity a four-time Emmy
winner for her work on newspaper drama
Luke Grant Martian added two more
nominations to a resume for portraying
Livia the second however came
posthumously in June 2000 the 71 year
old marshand died of cancer and chronic
vomitory disease The Sopranos third
season hit HBO in early 2001 and in the
episode proshai lavushka it's revealed
that Olivia soprano died in her sleep
having suffered a stroke
John Spencer worked extensively from the
1960s onwards frequently playing tough
and World weary cops lawyers soldiers
and a number of other authority figures
but they merely prepared him for his
signature role that of recovering
alcoholic and white house chief of staff
Leo McGarry on NBC's The West Wing
Spencer earned five Emmy nominations for
this role finally winning the prize in
2002. in the show's seventh and final
season McGary is picked to be the vice
presidential candidate on the ticket of
presidential candidate Matt Santos the
duo wins the election although McGary
doesn't live to see it he dies of a
heart attack in his hotel room on
Election night just before the polls
close
hey
he died Josh
this sad twist was necessitated by the
death of Spencer who suffered a fatal
heart attack a few days before his 59th
birthday in December 2005.
Andrew Campbell wasn't a main character
on Mad Men but he was an influential one
the stern aloof and disapproving father
of slimy young advertising executive
Pete Campbell made quite the mark on his
son's psyche he appears in just one
first season episode 2007's New
Amsterdam and could have eventually made
some return appearances if not for the
tragic and Unexpected death of his actor
Christopher Albert in January 2008
Albert was killed by an avalanche while
skiing in California's San Gabriel
mountains in the second season episode
flight 1 employees at the Sterling
Cooper Ad Agency listened to radio news
about an American Airlines flight that
crashed shortly after taking off from
New York city that is in fact an actual
tragedy that occurred in March 1962.
another Testament to the 60s set Show's
commitment to historical accuracy later
in the episode Pete learns that his
father was on the flight and that he
sadly didn't survive
Larry Hagman played one of the most
famous TV characters of all time but not
quite one of the most beloved from 1978
to 1991 he starred as backstabbing oil
magnate J.R Ewing on Dallas the Texas
Tycoon behaves so badly that somebody
was bound to take a shot at him and in
1980 somebody finally did the second
season of Dallas ended on a cliffhanger
when an unidentified attacker guns down
Jr leaving millions of viewers to wonder
if the character would survive he did
survive the shooting and Ewing went on
to survive another brush with death in
the final episode of Dallas when a ghost
convinces the Wicked Man to kill himself
whether Jr lives or dies isn't
explicitly revealed but modern fans can
assume he survived as he's a main
character in TNT's 2012 Dallas
continuation shortly after the 2012
Show's first season aired Hackman died
in November 2012 at the age of 81 after
a fight against cancer so Dallas decided
to have J.R Ewing die too and Ryder's
revived the who shot Jr slogan to do it
in a 2013 episode an unidentified person
puts a bullet in the industrialist later
revealed to be a setup by J.R himself to
arrange one more tricky business deal
while he dealt with his terminal cancer
portraying the dim but sweet Finn Hudson
on Fox's musical dramedy Glee was a
breakthrough role for Canadian actor
Corey Monteith the likable star anchored
the popular teen show for Four Seasons
all the while quietly struggling with a
powerful drug addiction his mother Anne
McGregor told ABC news that Monteith
started using drugs at 15 and struggled
with substance addiction off and on for
the next decade and a half in July 2013
the body of the 31 year old actor was
found in his Vancouver hotel room he had
died of a fatal overdose of heroin and
alcohol in October 2013 Glee aired an
episode entitled the quarterback in
which Finn's friends fellow club members
family and teachers all agonizingly
mourn their friend and colleague the
series also noticeably refuses to
discuss how Finn died
wants to talk about how he died too but
who cares One Moment in his whole life
fan is remembered frequently through the
rest of the show's run if you or someone
you know is struggling with addiction
please call the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health administrations 24 7
National helpline at
1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-4357
each and every episode of the warm
crackling low-key dramedy Gilmore Girls
features an odd credit special
appearance by Edward Herrmann the actor
appeared in many episodes so he was a
recurring cast member but this unique
introduction spoke to his status as the
best known and most esteemed member of
the Gilmore Girls Ensemble before he
portrayed the wealthy and impeccably
dressed Richard Gilmore Herman had
portrayed President Franklin Roosevelt
in multiple TV projects have been part
of projects such as American Playhouse
in Saint elsewhere and served as the
voice of the History Channel as the New
York Times aptly put it he had an
unmistakably Noble Heir Gilmore Girls
ended its original seven season run in
2007 but returned for four made for
Netflix movie length episodes in 2016.
in the interim Herman ultimately lost
his struggle with brain cancer spending
nearly a month in a New York Intensive
Care Unit before passing away in
December 2014. accordingly Gilmore Girls
a year in the life revolves around his
character's passing a few a few months
before the events of the miniseries
Richard Gilmore dies of a heart attack
leaving the Gilmore women particularly
his wife Emily in deep grief and
struggling to find a way to move on
Lee Thompson Young became a teen TV star
by playing a teen TV star as jet Jackson
on the Disney Channel's the famous Jed
Jackson he portrayed a young actor
struggling with Fame family and school
young successfully transitioned to more
adult projects but the most prominent
role of his adult life was that of Barry
frost on Rizzoli and Isles a detective
who often assists the titular Duo on
August 19 2013 young failed to report to
the rizzolian Isle set as expected
police went to his home to see if he was
all right and discovered that the 29
year old actor had taken his own life
the show briefly shut down production
and in June 2014 addressed the fate of
Young's character in the episode goodbye
Frost is revealed to have died
off-screen in a car accident and the
other characters attend his memorial
service if you or anyone you know is
having suicidal thoughts please call or
chat online with the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline at
1-800-273-talk 1-800-270 three eight two
five five
a versatile character actor Christopher
Evan Welch appeared in many films and TV
shows of the 21st century but he's
likely best known for what would turn
out to be his final role Peter Gregory
on Silicon Valley Welch appeared in five
episodes of the first season of the HBO
Tech World satire courted for his cash
by the main characters as they work to
launch a potentially revolutionary app
in December 2013 four months before
Silicon Valley debuted Welch died in a
Los Angeles hospital at age 48 following
a years-long battle with lung cancer
Silicon Valley waited until its second
season premiere in 2015 to mention what
happened to Peter Gregory Richard sees a
news item online about the investors
sudden death and later learns from
Gregory's associate Monica that he
keeled over during a safari while trying
to run from a stray hippo that had
wandered into his tent which In fairness
is a heck of a way to go
oh that is so very strange very sad very
sad that's true if nothing else USA's
2002 series Monk Is memorable for its
unique tone it follows a detective
Adrian Monk who often solves some
serious grisly crimes but monk is also a
comedy with plenty of carefully and
consciously kind humor derived from the
title character's obsessive compulsive
disorder helping to strike that balance
was the character of Dr Charles Kroger
amongst patient and helpful psychiatrist
who works with him to deal with his OCD
and lingering grief over the death of
his wife so it was a major blow to the
show when the actor who portrayed him
Stanley camel passed away from a heart
attack in April 2008. the first episode
of the show's seventh season the first
without camel aired in July 2008 with a
dedication to the actor it's mentioned
in dialogue that Dr Kroger similarly
died of a heart attack Angel is a show
about ageless beings and Supernatural
events so death isn't all that final a
concept for its various vampires demons
and angels when The Buffy the Vampire
Slayer spin-off premiered in 1999 there
were only three main characters one of
them being Doyle a half demonic hero who
receives alarming visions that vampire
detective Angel uses to solve his
Mysteries portraying the impish Irish
Rogue was Glenn Quinn previously known
for his work as Becky's near do well
husband mark on Roseanne in hero the
ninth episode of Angel Doyle sacrifices
his own life to save angels and never
appears on the show again however
frequent Angel writer and director Tom
Miner really wanted to bring Doyle back
he told an angel fan blog in 2007 every
once in a while I'd bring it up but I'd
get shot down any hopes of Doyle's
return were rendered impossible however
in 2002 When Quinn died of a drug
overdose at age 32. years later his
Roseanne character was also written out
of the show an episode of the 2018
reboot series mentions that that Mark
has died and ends with a dedication to
Quinn himself
it's arguably easier for an animated
series to handle the death of a cast
member as the performer's image is not
used producers can get a new sound alike
actor to take over a role vacated by a
death case in point actress gray DeLisle
Griffin became the new Martin Prince on
The Simpsons after the death of original
actor Russi Taylor in 2019 this is
largely because the show's writers were
anxious about killing off a child
character but that's not the direction
they took when Marsha Wallace died in
October 2013. Wallace used her
distinctive voice to play Bart Simpson's
sarcastic and long-suffering fourth
grade teacher Mrs krabappel for well
over 20 years as it turns out Wallace
simply wasn't replaceable and so her
character was retired about a week after
the 70 year old passed away The Simpsons
paid tribute in an episode's opening
credits Bart's chalkboard message that
week reads will really miss you Mrs k a
March 2014 episode includes an epilogue
in which krabapple's husband Ned
Flanders Daydreams about their good
times together
and is joined in mourning by one of her
students Nelson Muntz